Ukrainian officials say this was a
residential area until Russia's bombs
dropped overnight
now they hunt for survivors
the body of a woman found it's unclear
if she's alive or dead
this hell in the Northeast city of Sumi
is what families are desperate to flee
a humanitarian Corridor did finally open
here
young and old scrambled to escape
foreign students also caught up in this
war
it's the first successful evacuation in
Ukraine after three days of failed
attempts
but there's no relief yet for other
parts of the country the city of
mariopol in the Southeast is one of the
worst impacted
these images from yesterday show how the
turmoil is so extreme bodies at times
have been left uncollected in the street
we don't have electricity we don't have
anything to eat we don't have medicine
we've got nothing
[Music]
these empty shelves evidence of the
crisis
Ukraine's president even said a child
died of dehydration here
buses did move in to take families out
but Ukraine later accused Russia of
shelling the exit route
seeking perhaps to boost morale
president zielinski made a rare
appearance outside in the capital
it's snowing this is what spring looks
like the spring is similar to the war we
experience spring is harsh but
everything will be fine we will win
Russia has different ideas its defense
Ministry released these pictures of
Russian gunships opening fire
Moscow says it's not targeting civilians
but the reality on the ground has
prompted the fastest growing Refugee
crisis since the second world war the
city of leviv on Ukraine's border with
Poland is a Transit hub for those not
forced to wait for evacuation corridors
yulio and her three daughters are on the
move from Central Ukraine after her
husband told them to flee
[Music]
it was very difficult for me to leave
because my mother disabled grandmother
and sister are there my children can't
sleep at night they cry when they hear
air raid sirens and that's why we
decided it would be better for our
children to leave they plan to take
shelter in Poland where she hopes her
children at least will find some peace
debraham Sky News live in Western
Ukraine